how are you guys doing pretty good
um first of all thank you so much for
coming in and congrats for being part of
Comic-Con this year
um I'm so curious and I think um what do
you think fans would be surprised to
learn about what it's like behind the
scenes of making this series
well I think it's you know making an
animation cartoon is such a it's such a
group effort you know I think
everybody's surprised the amount of
people that it takes to make a cartoon
you know we have like so many
departments and our job as supervisor
producers you know we kind of like
oversee like every aspect of production
uh but it's really it really does take a
village so I think defense will be
surprised you know to like see the
amount of people that it takes to like
come up with one 22 minute episode
yeah I also think it's just how
dedicated DC fans are on the uh
production because there's so many
people on all parts of the process who
love these comic books love the movies
love the show who chime in and be like
oh well super mansion do that because of
this or Batman once did this and that
really that really helps you flesh out
how deep Harley Quinn's the Universe
goes just for people who can pull on
that wealth of knowledge well one of the
things the show does is it like flips
the script on like expectations like you
don't think certain things are going to
happen yet they do
um so I'm curious do you have a lot of
I want to write find the right words is
there a lot of resistance above when
you're trying to do things or do you
have a lot of creative freedom to just
sort of like throw it to the wind and
say we're going to do this
well I think we always start from the
point you know this is a story you want
to tell and this is how far we want to
push it you know and you know we put it
that way and then obviously sometimes we
have to make compromises you know
sometimes we take it a little far
I like how you say a little go on I'm
just joking around I'm joking yes but I
mean in general I think you know for
example DC they love the show over there
you know and they know that the show has
been very successful from season one and
I think they understand that you know
the show is successful because the humor
you know lies in putting these
characters that everybody knows and love
in this very very you know extreme
strange circumstances you know in this
like places where they usually don't go
um of course there's limits you know
like uh sometimes this is more precious
with some characters than others like
for example Batman you know or Superman
you know like with those characters you
know you have to be a little bit more
careful uh but again you know we always
try to push for the laugh and the comedy
you know and it's a back and forth you
know if we go too far you know and they
said you can't do that we'll take it
back a little bit sure if you don't mind
I'm going to switch to something else
which is I know that season four is the
trailer just dropped and you're here for
season four but I also know how long it
takes to do animation so just have to
ask uh uh you know are you working on
season five at all are you waiting for
this to come out to see what they're
gonna say
sure it's as strong as it can be so that
we can get another season so that
because we really want the fans to love
what we do here so I think the main
focus has just been let's finish this
let's get it out and make it as strong
as possible so that everyone this
resonates with everybody at home who
watches it so obviously what can you
tease about these upcoming episodes that
are literally about to drop
um well I think the fans are gonna are
gonna be excited to see like all the new
locations that we take them this season
uh we kind of expand out of Gotham and
we go to we have an episode in Vegas you
know where Clayface I see some new show
so he's in Total Diva mode uh we also
have we also go to the Moon I'm sure the
posts are kind of
tip that a little bit but uh Lex has a
giant villain convention in the moon so
that's the reason for the rocket uh and
we're also going to go to Italy with
pain to follow The Saga of the pasta
maker
uh a plus so when you are developing
these ideas and fleshing out what you
want to do during the season do you end
up coming up with like how do those
ideas get refined in terms of because
I'm sure you come up with a hundred
things and then it's ultimately well
what can we do or what do we want to do
you know we really try to give which you
know once after you get to the script
phase with the
the showrunner you really don't want to
pull your punches I think all of the
rest of the process is like how do we
make this bigger how do we make this the
biggest and coolest possible version of
this script you know and luckily our
production and the studio have been
wonderful about not having us try to
water anything down so I mean most of it
is making things larger you know like
making the robot fight the craziest
robot fight that you've ever seen you
know or the making the high-speed chase
as dynamic as possible we don't we
really don't try to pull back at all
because our show you know rests on being
as awesome as it could possibly be
totally I don't actually know if season
four is the same length as the other
Seasons um so my question is how many
episodes of season four and do you have
a favorite and why
uh we have 10 episodes for season four
and uh we're gonna see I think my
favorite episodes is the episode where
uh Ivy and Harley go to the future
we seen the clip inside the panel where
they steal the time which machine and so
we're going to see them like go to
another time space
I would say same I love that episode
you know General future Terminator guy I
love anything to do with the future and
it is a hilarious Harley Quinn and a
poison ivy episode uh outside of Harley
and Ivy do you have a favorite DC ship
you know like what you know what I mean
with the fans the way they ship
characters together
um well you know my favorite Disney show
has always been Batman the Animated
Series and I know this is an old one but
it's always been my favorite
um
I would say that my favorite is just
anything to deal with the new gods and
Darkseid and apocalypse sure
um one of the things is you guys did a
this great um uh problematic Valentine's
Day special
um is there any talk of doing more stuff
like that or extended episodes or you
know what I mean
um well at this time not that I'm aware
of I would love to do it uh the
Valentine's Day special was a very fun
and it was like a kind of like a almost
like a movie you know like a very like
self-contained movie you know and it was
it it was it was kind of like a
different format than a regular episode
so you get a little bit more time you
know to expand on the story and the
characters
um so the question the the I guess the
answer is no we haven't I haven't really
heard of anything and I don't think
anything is in the works yet but I would
love to do it well one of the things
about the show is I'm curious when you
want to do are there any new characters
that are introduced in season four that
we have not seen before
yeah plenty we have a lot of new
characters coming this season uh one of
the main ones is Talia al Ghul which
everyone knows about Talia and she's
going to come to Gotham as this is a
very powerful business woman and uh it's
gonna she's gonna become kind of like a
role model for Ivy who aspires to become
a good CEO of the Legion of Doom
and um we have a lot of new villains as
well we have a snowflame
um a snowflame is a DC character who
gets his super powers from a snoring
cocaine this is a real character I
didn't make him up and a lot of other
fun ones I mean we have weasel we have a
bounce boy and a Doleman in one of the
fights inside the Vegas episode
um we have Steppenwolf appearing in the
convention in the evil convention in the
moon and then besides that you know
we're going to see how like some of our
existing characters kind of take new
roles this season
sure one of the things about the show is
um there's so many people that talk
about it online and I'll be and I'm just
curious how much are you looking at what
people are saying and how much does that
actually get incorporated into what you
guys are doing in the writer's room
because I'll give you to put myself in
this
um on YouTube I'm either the best
interviewer or the absolute worst so
there is a way that I try to moderate
through the comments to find things that
are meaningful but I'm just curious if
you do the same I think a few times when
you read you read Ann's reaction it's
overwhelmingly supportive so when you
pass you know trolls or whatever you
know chiming in I think a lot of times
it's sort of like I don't think the show
is ever for you type of deal you know
but I would say usually when you're
reading them they're they're so
supportive and I think it does help you
know it's the positive stuff that helps
move the show because you see what
people are loving and then the next
season the writers and the show Runners
and everyone else try to give them the
things that they say that they want you
know I think because the show is run by
so many people who are DC fans you know
and just fans of Harley Quinn in general
they really want to give the fans what
they want because they're fans too so I
think it's the positive uh reactions
that get move this show and move the
dial of what we can do further
is there something that you guys have
put in the series that you still are
surprised you got away with
thanks
show is so extreme you know there's so
much Glory it's like so out there you
know sometimes I feel like man this is
too much you know but only no we never
really have been censored that much on
the violence uh we get sensors sometimes
on the nudity and the sex
um you know we try to be like tasteful
you know like we you know we don't have
really like frontal nudity but
um we don't we don't really get a lot of
censorship so I think we can we I
ultimately get away with a lot and then
sometimes the executives surprise you
you know where they have given notes on
sex stuff in the past and then for
season four there's a sex surrogacy
sequence and their note was more sex
stuff make this more outrageous like
they really wanted us to swing for the
fences of how crazy we can get so I
think if anything you're positively
surprised at how much they know the fans
wanted to go to that place they're like
no they should be like whoa crazy well
one of the things that I have to ask
like the popularity different show but
the popularity of the boys which really
pushes boundaries you wonder if that has
like a bleed over effect where
executives are maybe watching that and
saying well we can do that too and
Harley Quinn is the show to do it
definitely you know and I think it helps
like you feel like audiences are almost
desensitized you know to like a lot of
the violence and the you know all the
blood and you know guts exploded and
people being ripped in half you know
because they've seen it so much at this
point you know that you feel that it's
you know helping it make it a little bit
more acceptable you know like across
platforms sure one of the things uh what
does Harley what are some of the things
you can tease about Harley this season
that
um she's doing that I think fans will be
excited for
well I think I think the exciting the
exciting part about Harley this season
is that she's she's learned how to
become a hero you know we we saw her at
the end of season
being part of or starting to be part of
the bad family uh and the fun thing with
Harley is that she's really bad at it at
the beginning you know she's not good at
following rules she falls on her face
all the time you know it's like she
breaks the rule the rules and you know
the bad family is not happy about it so
she really needs to like find a way you
know to navigate this new role you know
and something that she doesn't feel
comfortable with because she's never
done it before
oh yeah and I think something the fans
are going to love is Harley gets his
outfit chain she gets she's part of the
bat family so she gets her own bat
outfit you know at being at Comic-Con I
think it looks great it's super cool and
fun when she gets it so I'm hoping that
in a year or two we'll be seeing bat
Harley's running around yeah I do enjoy
actually Comic-Con and I've seen so much
cosplay of Harley I mean you know it's
it's great but one of the things about
animation is a lot of things can change
when you're making it and it can be
refined but I don't actually know what
it's like for you guys like can you be
pretty far along and all of a sudden
realize wait maybe this isn't working
the way we needed to we need to redo
this and can you do that like how is it
in the behind the scenes
so many people involved in this process
you know know you always get like
curveballs you know sometimes I mean we
start with you know in pre-production we
you know start with the script and then
we do boards you know and then when the
boards are finalized you know like we
ship we ship it to the studio overseas
to get animated but you know before we
shift there's always like last minute
changes you know like maybe you know the
the xxi WB feels like you know this bit
you know the writing is like not quite
working or you know the this action
machine doesn't quite work you know we
need the characters to be more involved
and you know sometimes that comes late
in the process so you know but it's like
everything you know like you try to do
the best with the material that you have
you know and you make adjustments as you
go yeah and I think the largest thing
that you end up changing is just the
amazing work that all the voice Talent
brings to it because they do so much
improv sometimes like if you if you cut
an episode short and you know but JB
smooth is coming in you know he can just
come up with all sorts of hilarious
things that sprank the plant and you can
try to accommodate that as best as you
can or really all the characters just
really sometimes I knock it out a
partner like okay now there's an extra
12 seconds of hilarious poison ivy that
we have to accommodate for inside of the
episode and no matter where you are in
the process if the actors have come in
and done something like truly hilarious
you know you'll shift things around to
make sure you keep that performance in
the show totally
um we're at Comic-Con and I've been
asking everyone uh what do you geek out
over like if you go on the convention
floor what are you shopping for
um I don't know I love figurines you
know I saw the Dragon Ball stuff and
in the shoreline and I was really
excited about it uh so I love you know
the little statues and the figurines
sure
I think you know we actually have
overflow in our house right now we have
too much comic books too many figurines
too many statues but I love cells I'm
always in the market for a great
animation cell or new comic books I
collect New Gods you know she told me
not to collect comic books so this might
be news for her too I collect New Gods
comic books but I've been looking for
some keys around here you know I think
that's my big thing with Comics uh the
good news about this year is because
there's less uh Hollywood Studios on the
convention floor there's more dealers
and more Indie dealers uh it was really
nice uh in case you get time to walk
around on that note I really really
sincerely want to say thank you for your
work on Harley Quinn and I really hope
this season's a big hit for you guys
thank you so much